hey what's happening thanks for tuning
in another episode will have to be
talked today's episode is brought to you
by my fantastic sponsor el cajon Harley
the best Harley dealers in California
man if you're going to buy a Harley
Davidson or you want to get your bike
serviced or anything go down to my boys
el cajon Harley they've got all the
fantastic 2017 s on the floor right now
the new motors there the Milwaukee 8 i'm
getting ready to get myself a new road
king i need to upgrade i rode this thing
it's [ __ ] incredible time to upgrade
into the new machine head on down there
also elko and harley and la jolla comedy
store and myself are going to have a
bike nite at The Comedy Store it's going
to be a ride from El Cajon Harley over
to la jolla comedy store and then a
night of stand-up comedy so that's
coming in october or november waiting
for the date now that's going to be
fantastic don't miss that what a great
sponsor give them a call call up Greg or
follow them on Instagram or Facebook or
Twitter they're running them all they've
got everything you need there great shop
and there's a perfect time to buy 2016's
you can get a good deal on that if you
don't want the new motor they got great
financing rates going right now check it
out el cajon harlot yeah alright
everybody what's happening it's uh it's
a tuesday but this episode will be out
on thursday i'm just Spicer is gone as
dog is not feeling good that's always a
[ __ ] bummer and so he couldn't make
it today so I decided just to run some
run some stuff live here and see to some
conversations and talk about some [ __ ]
that I was thinking about today before I
came over to the shell and once in a
while I like to do that just run some
stuff by everybody first of all new
release records new where people always
ask me oh man what are you listening to
right now and it's pretty interesting I
a lot of people forget
records are out on Friday now which is
so [ __ ] dumb I don't know when this
happened I know when it happened but I
don't know why I don't know how it
happened all of a sudden just like you
know oh yeah we release them on friday
because more people buy on front and at
paychecks on Friday that's all [ __ ]
most people aren't even buying records
you know they're stealing them so it
doesn't matter what day to come out
they'll steal them on friday saturday or
sunday he'll steal him right after
church he [ __ ] robbers uart robbers
anyway and if my whole life records came
out on Tuesdays and new rare and new
movies came out on fridays so I don't
you know I don't understand it go back
to Tuesday's it was better it was like
just record freaks would slip into the
record store before the weekend you know
just looky-loos were in there and you
could just [ __ ] you know have hang
out in the record store all [ __ ] day
no one would be in there it was amazing
Oh bill OH cones here we might have jump
on the mic jump on the mic piddle my boy
Brenton Biddle comes here crazy oh this
one here did he just walked in he's in
luck he's going to be a co-host today
for a few don't worry about good man
right on anyway if you don't know Brent
and the BB combs on Instagram and he
opens for me we're coming to fresno when
is that that's October 21st 24th I think
24th something Oh what's got it in here
yeah looked at up real quick we're gonna
be out there and doing a show can't wait
for that Brent and uh when i first
started comedy and i went all over
California doing [ __ ] comedy and he's
from Ohio and so I took him to semut
which was insane mind-blowing yeah he'd
never been there imagine you're from the
terrible Ohio and then you just see
God's country i did i'm surrounded by
corn back home sir I'm unbelievable yeah
anyway here's a great thing we
you know actually there used to be this
killer comedy show up there was the name
of that place the river there Bass Lake
yeah my memories working today I went to
the gym it's [ __ ] working so we we go
to Bass Lake to do the show it was
incredible it's right before you semih d
and you'd go up to vacillate they'd give
you a badass cabin and you do comedy in
this bar not a bar it was stabbed as a
bar but it was like we're all these
people would go to vacation it was
really cool a jet skis on the lake and
[ __ ] and it was one of those shows you
like this ain't gonna last cuz it's good
yeah so we went up there and some guy
had a cold one of the tourist a [ __ ]
from stage and boom they don't do the
show anymore Mary that yeah yeah and we
got lucky that night he was on our show
he was actually supposed to be on our
show he had a migraine and couldn't go
on or he might have said [ __ ] and we
wouldn't been able to do our show that
was a great show to the whole town came
out yeah it was fantastic man we did
like three shows on that run one was
ridiculous in this sports bar that had
like nine people and it was like a
Sunday afternoon he had to do that's
that's where you wrote the tag for the
nuts to butts joke yeah what was it was
that the god the where you acted it out
were you saying the song oh yeah i saw
that drivers time you did now that was
the stage it was just a piece of wood
yeah it was it was a great yeah it was
like we're able tables so [ __ ] that's
how it is when you're on the road the
shitty gig you always wishes first but
it always seems to be last so it goes
good then great than super great and
then [ __ ] and that makes going home that
much better yeah you're just so
miserable in the way home but anyway
after we did the bass lake we rolled up
to Yosemite and just [ __ ] lost our
minds it was incredible anyway when you
walked in i was talking about how they
switch new release records from tuesday
to friday and it's just you know it just
feels weird to me still I kind of heard
through the door and movies are now like
thursday well yeah they're like late
Thursday night now and stuff like but
the weird part to me about it is um you
know Tuesday's was just so like people
don't even know i said hey the new st.
pound the broken bones is fantastic this
guy said oh when did that come out I
said Friday and he said oh I'm still
trying to get used to that [ __ ] coming
out on fridays people don't know you
know ya have it I mean with with the
internet now I mean you can you find
everything yeah they matter anymore dad
that's what I said people steal the
music on Friday Saturday me ba-- yeah
but I'm gonna talk about that right now
because people are all like guys
freaking out about it yeah they're all
like oh my god they're gonna tear it
down and it's going to be a high-rise
apartment now I moved here 15 years ago
because of what happened in San
Francisco and now it's exactly what's
going on in LA it's just [ __ ] what
happens is a city creates a cool
community of course la has been in my
eyes and maybe not in your eyes has been
cool since [ __ ] the beginning of time
everybody knows la like starts a lot of
trends clothing rock and roll beaches
motorcycles rock and roll clubs and and
and all that kind of [ __ ] in my eyes was
always just so next level in LA so cool
people come and and what happened really
when I moved here was Hollywood for
years was really dirty and shitty and
I've had many guests on we've always
talked about it like you know if you
lived by rock and roll Ralph's kind of
like where you live Torin all the way
towards Silver Lake it was just a
wasteland of drug dealing [ __ ] and
[ __ ] crime no no one was where I am
now it's good except for the 7-eleven at
the end of my street yeah exactly and
[ __ ] you 7 11 everyone has the [ __ ]
worst people cuz they're open all
I never zappers they never police him
that's the thing i ate they get you ever
notice said in front of 7-11 the
homeless guy you know he becomes friends
with a cashier cuz he's so lonely the
cashier that he'll talk to any garbage
can just to stay awake all night so you
got like a just a killer out front hey
you got any money man and then you don't
get many money you know then the [ __ ]
hound in you and the two three guys are
there all the time and you know it's
just insane but my point is your
neighborhood and all the way down used
to just be like we're rock and rollers
and new comedians and new actors would
all live and either live there for years
and get famous or tap out and get out
but it was always kind of a somebody
said a couple weeks ago I think it was
spicy something like 3,000 or 30,000 one
of the numbers we didn't get it yet a
month flips it changes 3,000 leave 3,000
come in or 30,000 whatever the number is
and and I think it's you know it's going
to be changing now because my point is
they're tearing down all the good [ __ ]
like on Sunset Strip they're getting rid
of all kinds of [ __ ] and putting hotels
up like the house of blues is gone and
then the corner of la cienega and sunset
wear the pink dot is that's a massive
working vegas hotel now then next to it
used to be that theater they put a
full-blown condos up there then hustler
magazine hustler store that's getting
plowed they're going to put a full
[ __ ] high-rise there with a nightclub
and everything and gwyneth paltrow as
part of the [ __ ] nothing there and
all the way up and am i and now they
released a story yesterday that said
amoeba is going to get bulldozed down
and turn into a high-rise condos and
hotels and my point is which it's like
it's it's just going to be hotels here
for the people to stay at with nothing
to do yeah there's gonna be nothing left
this is again come on to Holly
word that you heard about with all the
fun [ __ ] it's all gone just stay at our
pool and spend your money on our $25
drinks at this gonna be vegas without
casinos it's exactly what i said if you
want that [ __ ] you go to vegas where you
can [ __ ] get our cheap room you know
cuz they give you some cheap rooms to
get you in there to gamble and buffets
and all that stuff but this you know and
and and what ways me the most and all
the people say that's not going to
happen but what worries me the most is
how much can you say no to because from
what I'm hearing it's a lot of it's a
lot of oil money and guys that are
coming in they're just buying up
everything because they have so much
money so they're buying property and
you're talking about the comedy store
right I'm talking about the comedy store
yeah i'm talking about four million for
amoebas lot yeah i could be hard to say
no to that that's a lot of CDs you gotta
sell now now the amoeba thing we got a
call and we'll grab it right here and
then we're going to get into it hey
what's going on you're on the air hello
it's left okay until spessard in
Baltimore how long is it how r Spencer
howdy good man i love the Baltimore
that's great area out there yeah yeah I
mean it's uh it's got its ups and downs
but I but it's nice overall it's got
some sold out yeah i mean i sighs I seen
the wire yeah I'm ashamed to say I still
have to get around to it oh I can't
believe it I hate when people say that
you like I I always wonder how much do
you have to tell somebody something is
[ __ ] great before they look at it
it's crazy I don't know what the why
people were so leery i'm watching the
wire because this seemed to jump on any
[ __ ] show now like a you're watching
scooby doo you know like a whatever you
don't I'm saying you could go over
schooner you can go
all I did you watching the wire navin
started at what the [ __ ] together I mean
one of million Emmys yeah yeah yeah I'm
myself yeah I hear you know my wallet
we're talking about like Jenna fication
and and high rents and everything we mo
are often move to Baltimore what
happened so is everybody will move to
Baltimore and then all sudden the rents
will be eight grand there that's what
happens gonna keep going so what happens
people go like I gotta find a new city
to move dude they moved all the Portland
when i was living in san fran and the
rent or 2i everybody moved to portland
and seattle and all sudden that was
through the [ __ ] roof right now you
can't even move to Portland because uh
all the techies went oh I could work
from home so i'll own a house in
portland and man it's just crazy how
much is you run out there 1500 that's
between three people so i guess
comfortably that's not too bad why are
you being like 250 k headed 500 500 500
how shakes the place yeah first three
bedroom [ __ ] three bedroom 1500 did
that's why no one bedroom yeah I'm and
then and you're only paying 500 I could
hustle that on the street man you could
suck one good a month at a right hmm
anyway I'm calling on in la i'm coming
to see you at the store tonight oh [ __ ]
yeah i would show you going to and so
simple ATM oh yeah that's job that's
going to be incredible man rogan they
burke crasher badass did you get a
ticket hmm yeah we got circuit so I'm
sure well with the other food sold out
or wherever yeah I think it is yeah so
loud okay well well that's a good deal
i'll see if i wait yeah let's have a
drink man i'll meet ya what do all right
i'll be there at seven forty-five so
look for me on the patio
that place gets kind of crazy okay all
right thanks for the heads up yeah man
good thank you so much for coming
tonight man that's so cool are you were
on vacation yeah Oh [ __ ] badass i'll
buy you a drink wicked I'm sorry so good
work old lady buddy her Draya so anyway
amoeba now I had caught some wind about
this and now here then yeah they're
amoeba posted a letter I saw that too
yeah yeah and they said that's not
happening for years and and also amoeba
from what I understood had always wanted
to move anyway in the last few years to
downtown let's grab this call you know
be yeah who's calling where you come
from hi Jeff calling from Toronto hey
buddy how are at Toronto gentlemen how's
the weather today cool finally not
smoking hot for the last couple of
months kind of nice yeah right on man I
saw that I saw it was hot as [ __ ] Terry
sewing yeah with not not bueno but it's
good now so it's nice what's going on
dude well it can inculcate fights are
there to know it's a Brenton Biddle comb
the guy goes out on the road with me
sometimes comedian all right yeah be
doing our homes Detroit hey Kenneth I
wanted to call it i saw the topics i'm
not sure what you guys are talking about
but if something kind of i'm really
interesting around the idea of records
yep like releasing new records and
that's why we're talking to mike a click
pardon that's exactly what we're talking
about there you go so I guess my opinion
this is sort of state it would be if I
was in a band right now I would only
really single absolutely that's a little
more sin maybe once a month or something
like that to stay relevant and just drip
out singles exactly it's like the 50s
that's what they did an offense i'm
simply around it like Elvis used to me
I'd make records already compile them
right it's just like the fifties its
goods turn into the 50s again because
back then you know you'd have to tour
with like five or six groups to get the
people
out so you'd have like you know the
famous one big bopper ritchie valens and
you know the deal is okay buddy holly
those were tours that were a standard
they would load up one tour bus like
Motown put all their groups in it they'd
go around America because each band had
like three songs so they need to play
five songs and it would be a 15 song
concert and they'd be out of there and
it's coming it's coming down to that now
because other than the top five which
would be Springsteen you to Metallica
stones there's a few more you know that
don't tour much Roger Waters stuff like
that those are the only ones that can
fill these [ __ ] arenas and the rest
are you know they need four or five
bands to do it you know so even if
Philomena but here's the thing though
like I love live music actually one of
those guys is a bit of a snob so I love
to go to smaller shows any way smaller
than he is mm-hmm so if I can go out
like for example like I know like we
have a lot of similar tastes in some
ways but like I love keep yarn I learned
my favorite guys right lovin been trying
to get him on the show for two years
right so he drops it out which is
amazing called an ancient time which is
great yep and so I love to be able to
get all that new music and one so I love
it but I still get a chance to go down
and you know it's like a hundred bucks
at a local venue small venue I can get I
can go to medium I didn't even greet for
what's a relatively reasonable price and
see a guy that I love with a full
catalogue out of like a bend that maybe
has 750 or thousand people well
unfortunately that's about as the size
that Pete Yorn can play he doesn't want
to play that probably he'd like to be
playing like theaters you know to me the
ultimate is theaters for rock or comedy
I think it's fantastic size once you get
to the arenas you got a lot of
part-timers that are like oh to these
guys or I'll go what the [ __ ] are you
know but when you get into a theater
they sell out quick i'm talking about a
1200 to maybe 2,500 right in there those
rooms are electric and i've been in tons
of them across America
they are fire because there's two things
going on the people have paid and are
really excited to be there like holy
[ __ ] were in this theater to see this
and they bring someone with him like a
date or whatever and the perform is
excited he's like [ __ ] man the theaters
fool and it gets electric you know clubs
are definitely cool but I sometimes have
a hard problem with the sound in them
you know like this place sounds like
[ __ ] you know like the clubs are there's
some great clubs like the rocks you know
ever you ever had it wherever audit
whether it's likely i remember one band
a group enemy in the 90s called genes
whether the Smiths have been but they
were playing kind of slow ballad type
songs and there was like a pump from a a
beer keg I'm gonna pop it off like haha
that's accorded if I Corey [ __ ] guys are
right I'm agitated I've actually seen
some marina bands play clubs and they'll
bring an arena system in and you're like
what he had till then dude it's just
like just killing you man volume-wise i
don't know i like all rebels i love
seeing a huge band at a secret gig at a
club that's probably one of my favorite
things it's like oh my god you know like
such and such as playing the Roxy like
Springsteen 75 imagine he played the
Roxy that's just unbelievable after he
does for hours at the forum I'm born to
run to her he goes to the roxy and place
till five six in the morning that [ __ ]
is fire see radio edit the troubadours
[ __ ] like that that stuff you never
forget but i love the theaters men and i
think they're I think they're underrated
there's so many great theaters out there
awesome well neither thought so so so
look I'm talking about tribesmen mark
but I want to bring it up to around
records is that I just think that in the
quest to put up these records that the
quality is gone way downhill and for the
example of these about to talk opposite
about the stables is like I think about
whether my sweet spot was when Joshua
Tree came out also I was in high school
a great nine grade 10 and there's a
record
d traps on that record like mothers will
be disappeared and redhill mining town
like this the whole record is fire right
yeah you can connect and you wouldn't
have those songs right like your favor
just releasing singles I don't know if
they never get around so that's how you
didn't find those thoughts well you and
they're like actually my brakes
adolescent your tape okay you're talking
about a band that knew how to write
songs here's the problem songwriting is
[ __ ] crazy hard so is joke riding a
lot of bands they'll get lucky not lucky
the work hard or whatever and they'll
have one or two great [ __ ] songs
that's already impossible to write one
[ __ ] hit song is super hard because
everything that happens to make it is
like beyond what you got you could even
imagine so when you get a chemistry
which is a missing in a lot of bands
we're talking four guys that started a
band when they're 14 or whatever in
junior high you two you know that's
called chemistry guns and roses you know
they [ __ ] move out here they're
they're eating [ __ ] out of the
garbage you know their living off in the
studio whatever you're gonna get some
[ __ ] to sing about but now it's like
this guy looks good put them in the band
that guy looks good put him in the band
this guy's going to write a hit song cuz
he knows how to write the hits and
that's what it is you know so it's it's
if you know that's where the singles
work it's like here's a band they got
one song I didn't get burned look I got
a [ __ ] load of [ __ ] songs in my
itunes one song from a band that I love
and I put it on once in a while go this
song was so great you know there it is
it serves its purpose you know waiting
baby to that in order days used to have
to go by the whole record and sometimes
you get totally burned oh oh I've time
when it's you fun and I was amazing and
then you're stuck with this recognize
never listen to you all oh I grew up for
my bravery the brain raw fish records a
lot of
Enza played Coachella over the last 10
12 years I went through my CD collection
and I'll be like other Coachella files
cuz you'll be you'll get caught up in it
like goddamn that bama is great and you
realize it was really the weekend the
friends you were with the surroundings
you run out and buy this CD and then it
is sitting like what happened to these
guys I got a shitload of those bands you
know after Sherman but and also like I
said I grew up poor man when I bought a
bad record I still know the bad records
right now in my head they've aged in my
brain of like uh I made the wrong show
no it's not that cost a lot of cash flow
you can't get back on your paper and
that was only 6 99 dig that was 699 that
aint [ __ ] twenty dollars you know
hilarious 699 scarred me thanks for
calling man awesome chicka yeah have you
bought a record that you were bombed on
I've got a few yeah yeah and they just
sit there right I don't play them I know
what you why don't you trade a minute
amoeba uh well because it's not gonna be
there much longer apparently now we got
another call man this is the most cause
we've had in a long time bit old man you
[ __ ] getting the calls hey what's
going on you're on the air hello hello
hello how are you who's calling where
you calling from hey i'm calling from
vista california san diego county oh
yeah you're gonna buy a Harley at El
Cajon Harley oh man where'd you say I'm
watching you online while talking you so
it's kind of like oh I'm do I will turn
it turn me on lines yeah mon yeah yeah
yeah now just now I just turn turn to
the vocal you mark I'm just looking I'm
just staring straight at you right now
yeah right on your rubbin one out or
what yeah 3 Pittsburgh hmm oh yeah sorry
I'm a little strong a little headstrong
compliance oh yeah what's going on buddy
no man I'm just uh you know i was just
searching the youtube waves and i was
like oh [ __ ] well I've podcast right now
should call so yeah I did hit you up and
see what's what's good you know what you
must have nothing to do in life hey
who's just sitting around surfing
[ __ ] YouTube like hey there's 1 i'll
call this is where we still need
blockbuster Wow blockbuster now people
are just on youtube looking for things
man are you wealthier you are you just
unemployed [ __ ] but I'm King all
second mom tonight can I talk to you
like a few minutes Yeah Yeah right I get
it all right yeah I'm just you know
chillin in San Diego I wanna you know I
i love the commedia dell'arte so i
decided to do you look a call a yeah
yeah pretty good pretty good prank call
did you know but here's what i recommend
you should probably had a job did not
matter even are you are you hiring do
you know like anyone yeah they're yeah
you just cut him off like that that's
how we do it here man although guys
actually have what is it it's [ __ ]
tuesday at three o'clock they're just
have time mom come on him on the phone I
know the dumbest yet race when he did
that he gave him several was like come
on anyway what were you saying bit him
uh was I talking to me but we're talking
about amoeba I wanted to ask you to by
the way this is off topic but since you
stopped doing music for a few years do
you still write music I don't because
you have that tool yeah yeah I do but
the I could do it it's writing music for
me is really [ __ ] easy which is weird
it's the lyrics that take a wall lyrics
are easy to write if you don't give a
[ __ ] whether Santa jokes if you don't
give a [ __ ] what you're saying I would
have [ __ ] for hours of comedy right
now if I was just doing step from the
first two three years but just from from
doing years of stand up nothing's really
sparked where you're like I'm gonna
write a song about that now because the
thing is I I don't really a it that it
it doesn't drive me any more comedy is
my dry that's exactly when I first star
music you know what I mean it's just my
[ __ ] it's like if you it's like if
you did whatever you do in life I tell
people this if you did it for so long
you did it yeah and I mean like I'm sure
there's comedians out there that look at
you and I and just go like I had gone to
open mics and I like I remember those
days there's a burnout and of that and I
wasn't burned out or whatever but when
you've done something so long and the
amount of work that it takes once you do
write the songs and then go record them
and then what are you going to do or
whatever I'd rather put that energy into
my stand-up and my podcast and I really
as cheesy as this sound have zero really
zero time you know like see if I'm home
last night I took the night off and I
was like off the night off and I just
listened to some records and i was
looking at this new metallica book I got
and I was like this is so [ __ ] rare
and I took that night off last night our
purpose cuz i looked at the schedule and
what whoa this is a [ __ ] massive load
coming up of work i'm just gonna sit
here tonight you know what i mean and i
think as i remember people telling me
early on you need to do that because if
you don't you just become kind of a
robot on stage you get you just like you
know you just saying this stuff not
because you're just over and over and
over don't same act every night yeah you
got to kind of feel the I almost like
the danger now of what I do take a night
off before I used to think I don't want
to take a night off its weird onstage I
like the weird now because or else if
it's to surgical and perfect to me I get
a little bored you know do you ever get
like that like this stuff's all working
its jacking great and you know to me the
thrill is a perfect example there was a
really bad show in
ozona last week it was just I threw some
people out they were just a drunk girl
and everything and now i'm at the very
bottom and I in my mind I was like all
right I gotta fix this the rooms pretty
full I got to bring it all the way back
up and I enjoyed the challenge at the
end of the show we forgot about the
people that were thrown out you know I
like that you know you need the variety
you need the very same night same thing
every night and it goes the exact same
way you lose that adrenaline you lose
that yeah feeling that you get that
makes you want to do it yeah the
adrenaline and the fear are really great
tools of comedy man day because they
make you [ __ ] they make you get down
and and really focus and like all right
let's [ __ ] do this if you don't have
the adrenaline and the fear it's almost
like its robotic and you don't want
hecklers no but they keep you sharp yeah
mm-hmm so you need them every now and
then even though if you're a heckler out
there [ __ ] you and you should die and
yeah interesting thing I'm not going to
say who the comedian was but I was
talking to two comedians yesterday and
one comedian told the other comedian and
this is how this came up I was in
Arizona over the weekend and I was in a
motorcycle crash one year ago I'm still
pretty up I can move and everything's
great but my neck still [ __ ] up a
little and also sometimes my knees or my
hat whatever you know this guy and I've
talked about this over and over he was
drunk he came up he [ __ ] picked me up
in like a bear hug like yeah man and I
just [ __ ] smashed him you know like
dude I was in a [ __ ] motorcycle crash
you know he just grabbed me like we were
12 year olds in a playground I'm like a
grown man just did two hours of comedy I
don't even know you hey there is drunk
yeah you know he grabbed me in a fool
bear hug and picked me up and I was like
ah [ __ ] his [ __ ] and I say yeah I'm
55 and I weigh 120 pounds that's gonna
happen my entire life number
wait everyone look up q you picked up at
Tyga out of it for work this woman
grabbed my cheek you so cute ohh my god
[ __ ] grown man speaking of smashing
people did you see the video that seven
year old that was playing rugby now he's
like twice this a might have been eight
but he's like twice the size of
everybody yeah he's just trucking people
over oh no funny the [ __ ] the boy I
was just knocking kid then they're all
half a size it's my thing is nothing
fair my thing was one comic had heard
about it and he was he said yeah a comic
had told him watch out what you put out
there because your audience will become
that kind of like I love rock and roll
but I don't want the audience to be like
it's like at a rock show where they go
when they're commenting like yeah okay
you know all right oh you're doing bits
and stuff it's a different animal comedy
compared to the [ __ ] you know the
Slayer concert that we're at you don't
oven and I'm not complaining i like the
people to come out but i don't like that
kind of thing of you know this guy just
bulldoze to me here and I mean so that's
a really a big big thing to of that's
why I like to talk about all kinds of
[ __ ] on the podcast you know people try
to box it in of like they just talk
eighties rock and I'm like dude that was
like four years of my life and what I
took out of it was gnr and and jane's
addiction or whatever you know what I
mean some judas priest and maiden but
it's not my whole life and some people
it's their whole life and I grab that
they gravitate towards that and be like
yeah you know what I mean all music
sucks now right like no it doesn't like
[ __ ] you know like it's funny man but
uh it's interesting you know because you
get into a thing of like I love all the
people coming out and the support but
man don't [ __ ] grab on me you know I
was pretty heated what he did was mad
yeah yeah that's just you get past the
age we're a teenager and that's assault
yeah yeah
the thing was it wasn't it like that it
was just a drunk man and it was like why
would you grab someone and pick them up
also those people that like to try to
squish your hand when you're shaking
hands yeah they try to give you the grip
like you shake yeah man it's like [ __ ]
you don't squeeze my hand I've been
riding motorcycles all my my hands are
[ __ ] brittle man they're like [ __ ]
old I'm old I'm 50 man hmm it's funny
cuz i was uh i read this big article on
Springsteen and Vanity Fair and I'm
obsessed with Springsteen's endurance
and his his broader double his body
right now there's a picture of mine
instagram i put it up and he's like in a
forest or something looked like they
were out like hunting or something you
got a shirt off hey guys like 62 or
something and he just looks [ __ ]
dynamite and I was reading it what's
this the rugby guy at your own beast
mode oh there's nothing worse than I
hate then the word beast mode why don't
you like beast mode hey because that's
the dude that grabbed me oh really yeah
we're not saying that there's no other
way to describe this thing isn't be
smoked yeah that's crazy that is but oh
oh yeah Brenda this guy first of all he
looks nine I would question his age yeah
first I love that like when I played a
little big they had a guy that pitched
in he had a beard the god of beer like
he just made shared pretty [ __ ] her
it's like no he's 17 and moving this
guy's just taking dudes just throwing
kids over its it funniest things
actually funny man i wish i could see
his parents goddamn that's funny well
yeah tell them what it is so they can
see it online uh look up eight-year-old
goes full beast mode it's just this like
really big little kid just throwing kids
to the ground plane rugby on youtube
yeah it's on youtube it's not even fair
right anyway my thing on Bruce is
excellent story on him in Vanity Fair
this month he's got a book coming out
called boy
run that he wrote himself after the day
after he played the Super Bowl he
decided to just write it in his diary
about what it was like to play the super
bowl and then he decided that seven
years ago and decided this slowly was
like a I think I got something here he
started writing a book comes out as
doing a [ __ ] in store at barnes and
noble at the grove which doesn't say
which by the way trying to get burrs on
this podcast every listener yeah his
twitter he's got a twitter let's see if
we can do this just say hey when you're
in la october third why don't you do
something totally outside the box and do
Dean Del Rey's podcast I don't think
Bruce is Danny podcast and I'm afraid
he's going to end up doing one you know
and it's like to have Bruce on it's a
it's a million zillion zillion to one
but I how to me it seems like something
Bruce would do he'd be like what could
we do to give back to the people you
know well what did she do a podcast do
you like this guy's podcast when you're
in la man it'll get so much press yeah
Willie it gets a lot of press for the
star like Haley he does barnes and noble
and then he comes over to the all things
comedy studio and does Desiree's podcast
you and I mean that would be insane
anyway my point is oh we got a call
let's grab it real quick hey what's
happening you're on the air who's
calling Chris from New York hey again
Chris from New York yeah hey I'm coming
out to New York i'll be there October
twelfth through the 18th man can't wait
her eighteenth of Gotham come down man
and then the stand the whole rest of the
time awesome awesome yeah what's going
on cilla so yeah there's local New
Yorkers for you to interview if you
didn't do the podcast over there again
right what's that you said you remember
you get few podcast shows out of New
York when you visit it yeah i'm pretty
sure i'll probably do Bobby Kelly's
again hopefully I can get on
Jim Norton's rate you know o bein Jim
I've been trying to get on that thing
for two years you know oh yeah I wanted
you to talk to you and again I know it's
pain the ass you want people to make
require some stuff like that I'm sure
but I thought it'd be cool for you to
talk to degeneration single Jeff and
Alain oh you know I really wanted to
talk to him last time i was in new york
i was actually there the night they
played New York and I didn't have I
didn't I know Jessie I mean Bree briefly
we met a few times through Jakob Dylan I
died at mana be great because he is one
of the great New York rockers and he
loves Springsteen also and spring Sun
birthday yeah Springsteen sang on his
last record and yeah and and he's a
great dude and he's and he's a [ __ ]
hard work I'd love dat Mon so if you
know how to get ahold of more anything
have me email me at dean del rey @
yahoo.com and i would have him on in a
minute yeah maybe I can I mean um I I
learnt that guy right just going to his
club yeah now he has the club there that
that one on the street I walked by Odin
east village is that his now bowery
electric yep I walked bite every [ __ ]
night man when I come home from the
stand I'll stay in the east village I
walked by every day you know cuz I was
over and a real bike ride by the lansing
yeah exactly so I walk by it every night
what's up I said I stalk did pretty good
as a joke I posted a photo but we do
that so I said I know where he's ipod to
lansing yeah yeah you could you could
just step on in there he's probably
there some nights or just asked to
borrow or whatever and yeah like you
said you connected the dots real quick
he is Friends of Bruce so yeah no no no
yeah that'd be great if you see him
please pass on my info I actually know
his ex-girlfriend maybe she can set it
up all I'll text her tomorrow and find
out lost Jacob tonight I'm going to see
petty tribute to Tom Petty tonight all
these [ __ ] killers are playing at the
fonda
and I'll ask him to set it up but thanks
thanks for coming in did he got any
questions yeah definitely I had a few
topics because um I was going off of you
guys were talking about earlier
specifically you know I would and the
rents in anything like that yeah and I
know as far as New York I've read and
I've seen you know comedians and
musicians and kind of lips pressure to
stay in certain places you know I'm not
going to name exactly where they are you
know but I'm just key places with these
real estate agents like a you can go
here go here and it's like I don't know
what is the deal I mean whether you're
in the hills or your these these little
towns within New York City what is the
deal with eyes that like peer pressure
or why do people feel like they need to
be in certain places somebody in the
building it's not peer-pressure know its
location yeah and it's the vibe of the
place oh yeah it worked fine when you're
around creative people yeah like look I
could easily live in like Valencia like
an hour away like say we're magic
mountain is for like crazy cheap yeah
but you are not going to get up and
leave the [ __ ] house after a while
you're going to be depressed and and and
even when I'm living right now you don't
really relate to the people around you
it's a lot of people that have families
and kids and everything and you need
inspiration you need [ __ ] the joggle
your mind man and if you're just stuck
in some suburb like let's say the
outskirts of jersey and and you don't
really relate with what you're seeing
you're not going to be creative and also
you start to get lazy like ah I'm not
going to go into the city tonight again
I'm just gonna watch TV and I've seen it
I've always lived no matter what the
price is right in the [ __ ] fire
because it keeps you relevant and it
keeps you hungry and it makes you work
harder like goddamn this is [ __ ] hard
man i can't pay rent and you either tap
out or you keep working but if you're a
couple hours away or or even a guy told
me he live
doubt bike by the [ __ ] what's the
amusement park I went out to their Coney
Island guy said he lived out there yeah
thirteen hundred dollar one bedroom yeah
but he's 40 minute ride in you know
every day and 40 on the way home and a 2
a.m. at 40-minute train ride home after
a while you start going like man this
sucks you know and you don't want that
you need like as hard as his businesses
you need other things around it easy you
know like bittle come lives [ __ ] two
blocks from the store I walked three I
want he walks everywhere so that it's
not a pressure there's no pressure at
all it's just you know if you live
somewhere else you're going to tap all
yeah cuz i was on the west side when I
got out to LA it was way cheaper but i
would spend an hour and a half in
traffic and then as soon as i started
paying more and lived closer i was
happier the less time I spend in the car
you know the more time I'm around comedy
yeah I look at it was like if I live in
New York like I've been thinking about
it if I could just make around five
grand a month which is a lot of [ __ ]
money I would have places in both I
would have my place right now and then I
would stay in some studio in the city in
Alphabet City you know and have them
both and I would just live back and
forth man and I would be crazy happy mmm
gotcha gotcha I meant I mean even if you
look at a not to get too deep into this
ball just hit one more thing about it
like you look at touring acts and you'll
see a single or a guitar player from
different bands in there there's no
there's no reason for them to really be
that I don't see it you know as far as
them being spar anything like that even
like Iggy Pop years ago he was my record
Avenue B oh yeah and he said he said you
know New York doesn't have you don't
hear people say yo anymore you don't
hear I heard that I heard that yeah he
so it's not in the Sun you know as far
as hot and so I design comedian side get
it yeah
medians we have to be around the club's
every night now if you're a musician
believe me man if I was a musician of a
famous one like Iggy Pop then once
you're famous you can live anywhere you
[ __ ] want because you just come to LA
for a month and work and then you you
know you make a record you can make
records anywhere now back in the day you
step to go to la New York San Fran to
the big studios and record for a month
or so and then go out on tour now you
[ __ ] hook up a full studio in your
house and you can live in like [ __ ]
Pittsburgh I was on Pittsburgh guys like
man you could write some [ __ ] records
here you know so and a lot of cities
because of hipsters people think
hipsters are lame and I totally disagree
with that a lot of cities have hipster
areas and all every [ __ ] city has one
whenever I get to see like a where's the
record store and they go oh it's that
way Neal Brennan the Holy says when
where's the you know he's got one like
where's the vegan food you know what I
mean it's going to be where's the good
coffee at whatever that's going to be a
cool where's the denim shop where's the
records denim coffee had [ __ ] vegan
and you're going to find some kind of
some hip neighborhood so with music it's
kind of easier because you're not
playing every night in the local scene
like you know what I mean not like the
old days all days you you know a scene
would happen like Seattle or San Fran or
[ __ ] in New York or Austin or whatever
those were scenes because the rent was
cheap and people landed there and you
could play music and there was clubs but
with comedy you can't just move to
Pittsburgh and go wild literally now for
750 but I only go on once a week now if
you want to be a road comic than it
doesn't [ __ ] matter you can live
anywhere where Alfie may he's got a
[ __ ] place in allston I believe or
nashville sorry nashville stanhope lives
in the middle of nowhere Arizona but
those guys are established comedians and
they can just get out on tour and play
great rooms and then right on the road
like we have to write and go to clubs
and try the stuff you know well you know
you hit something and you said something
earlier which kind of jobs together I
don't know if you have a thought about
this way but hipsters and techies are
you know so i live in at the same area
as far as i can see new york right and
they're changing the areas and i'm
making it less me you are it a little
bit more comfortable whether it's the
yogurt place or the nice food happy like
you're talking about I understand what
happens is sometimes some of the soul
gets out of the city like I've been a
good girl say like yeah I I get it but
try living you think all the souls out
of New York or San Fran or LA try living
in a suburb it is [ __ ] kill yourself
it's a strip mall with a target a costco
I'll [ __ ] what's that other big one
this the super stores Walmart's and then
it's and then the restaurants are Panda
Express olive garden and angle B oldest
[ __ ] [ __ ] so I'll take the yoga
studio and all that in New York over all
that because I travel everywhere and if
i drop got dropped in the middle of
somewhere I couldn't tell you where I am
because it all looks the [ __ ] same
the houses looked the same as I fly in
ago I don't even know where we're flying
in right now we could have been hijacked
and we're just flying into Oklahoma
Mississippi maybe we're flying into
[ __ ] you know Toledo whatever it's
all the same and yeah but yeah I effort
other comics say the same exact thing
you just said and from what I saw from
being a little kid growing up here in
New York I saw the little bookstore and
the little record store become a chain
bookstore in the chain records so like
I'm a mega music store a mega bookstore
become you phase that out now it's a
[ __ ] target where the mega book store
in my neighborhood was so it's not it
doesn't matter
you are it does it's going to come it's
all coming down it is all coming next
it's just all greed you know what I mean
and it all starts with rent that's what
happens as soon as a building owner
realizes he can get more money for his
building it takes a different person to
move in and pay that rent and and
especially if we're talking about
bookstores record stores guitar stores
and small mom and pop restaurants it's
the landlord and I seen it in SF growing
up there yeah the landlord goes I've had
this guy here 20 years this is the best
pot stickers in America but you know
what I don't care cuz I can get another
[ __ ] 500r in on this you're out of
here and then the guy goes Wow where am
I going to go and he goes I don't care
and then Panda Express goes in there and
it all comes down to greed of rinse and
and you know that's the bottom line if
if people didn't pay the rent it
wouldn't [ __ ] go up and I thought I'm
in an invite and like I said people like
you said it's these places that can
afford to lose for two years until they
make a profit three years later but
exactly are these locations right I just
kind of ask you because I know the
communes you've got a mix of fans where
they come from they might come from
abroad they come from out of state or
some some people from the city just so
it's a nice mixed yeah but as far as
music is concerned I see and so far
because your buddy their kind of looks
like Billy Corgan ins I saw Beverly
cordon and I mean that's couple met my
friends so don't worry about me cool
bomb you know when he had hair yeah
right here Yeah Yeah right first record
what's a Geisha whatever it's called yes
yes yeah that'll kick ass record yeah
anyway Billy Corgan was interviewed by
Steve Jones and he was just saying you
know today we have fake indie we have
fake Punk we have faked this and that
and and then he just kind of of course
on his Billy Corgan way just breaks
everything down which he's an
intelligent guy so but I was just
thinking about it like fans it's like us
genres and you have fake fans you know
kind of come to the city it doesn't
matter what city wherein they kind of
try to dress like they sink for people
in that city dress like it's like a
little high school to wreak extremely
cliquey and I'd rather say hey [ __ ] all
you get the [ __ ] out of here just you
know um but but as far as that's
concerned I think that kind of dictates
who's famous in music because I see
people armed that are complete I'm sorry
but [ __ ] complete [ __ ] I mean
just like Yemen you know chart trying to
do genres like and I'm not trying to get
our soap box I'll make this quick I'm
just saying as far as like people going
ok i'm not i'm not locked and i'm not
this i'm kind of a mixed [ __ ] if you're
good been able to just be straight at
Brock yeah like but here's the thing I'm
stands are buying it it's it's it's no
different now than [ __ ] you know 50
years ago if you look back at the
Beatles they were great there was a
million fake Beatles you know what I
mean if you look back at Zeppelin
there's a hundred zipper you know what
I'm saying we just don't know about them
now but it's always there's always junk
around the good stuff and it's always
going to be like that I think the main
thing now is just like I really don't
know where the where all the artists are
going to be able to live and I don't
know how people are going to be able to
do art and in and i say this i said this
15 years ago when i moved from san fran
and then I moved to LA and I went oh my
god i'm paying a thousand rent and
people are out at night this is [ __ ]
great man and now i can see exactly what
went down in SF is going down and my
point is if i want to pay this much rent
and this [ __ ] craziness all live in
this new york where it's [ __ ] rad you
know them in [ __ ] it I never lived in
New York because it was [ __ ] thirty
five hundred dollars for one bedroom but
if it's going to be like that all over
America might as we live in a great
[ __ ] City where I can walk around I
can subway excellent [ __ ] subway
system killer food beautiful women great
calm
he seen [ __ ] it you know I mean that's
the bottom line man it's how you're
gonna drive us all to New York it's
gonna be there's gonna be ten thousand
dollar rents cuz people are gonna move
to New York oh man only paying 500 more
than I was in LA and I'm in New York
this is great you know you know a
statistics people were leaving your can
droves for the past couple of years to
but yeah maybe they're not going to do
that now that things are changing around
all swear yeah thanks for calling in man
Oh real quick couple more things real
quick watching are ya did you talk about
Izzy anywhere yeah because it is just
like it's just a it's just a game he put
up the thing where he said you know they
didn't want to split the money equally
and you know it there was no mystery
that some of the guys aren't there
because of money you know and if he
didn't think that's what it was about
your crazy but I also think that is it
was the first to quit why would he think
he could come back and get the same
amount as the other guys who had been in
the trenches for [ __ ] 20 years
promoting the thing you know what i mean
so I mean if I quit a job meo let me put
it this way if i work at [ __ ] burger
king and I quit burger king in 89 and i
was making three dollars and thirty-five
cents in 89 that was the minimum wage
and then I go back to Burger King and
[ __ ] 2016 and go look man I want
equal cut as the manager it's just not
going to happen you know what I mean it
and I love how people jumped on that but
he quit the band he quit wait a second
wait a second yes a second there's a
couple of ways we look at it and yeah
everybody's looking at your way right
and a business insider who works with
them said well you know he wasn't going
to drive in many more fans and tick
itself and so what the hell and they
kind of that he made it sound like they
saw it offered him a cameo and since
when if they're a cameo in a rock band
that's where movies shut the [ __ ] up
with that either you're in or out but as
that's concerned he's a mean writer as
far as i can remember an absolutely
business there's a literature in another
record and it's the future another tour
because isn't isn't i'm having just the
three guys and this kind of i'll say it
man screw if i use me it's a circus act
behind them um other than that kind of
laying after a while is aren't people
going to fizzle out well here if you
have guys if you don't understand how
rock business works it works like this a
couple [ __ ] money people get behind
closed doors and go look man offer him
this if he says no we'll go out and run
this thing to the ground and then we'll
give them the right amount and you think
they're not going to come back next year
with Izzy maybe and [ __ ] Adler and do
I know yeah yeah I'm just saying axel
it's a slow building block anytime guns
gets a little slow oh [ __ ] duff mckagan
is playing with him for two weeks that's
crazy all sudden it's like 80 to me holy
[ __ ] Adler showed up like mid tour
ticket sales were a little soft on those
re on those baseball parks Adler played
a couple now people like that or might
show up in arms let's get ticket you
know what I mean that's it business but
but bottom line is um you know yeah is
he wrote the tunes and yeah you know
it's like I'm sure he probably was
offered maybe 10 million probably what I
want the same amount 10 million they
said they said five figures per show
yeah a meow come on man [ __ ] being a
time in also when you know you gotta
look at it it's a business now it's way
different than back then now it's like
is he could say I'm in and then four
shows in quit and leave him hanging and
now you know what I mean it's too much
money on the line it's [ __ ] that was a
hundred and eighteen million dollar tour
so you can't have a guy go you know what
I realized you know and look dude I'm a
huge [ __ ] izzy stradlin fan huge you
know but I'm saying you can't have a guy
just go I'm out I this do isn't for me
you know
mucc receives into the money yet shut
the [ __ ] up and do it I got it yeah all
right we got to go man thanks for
calling in brother thank you you got it
man see you man that was the longest
color ever real quick yeah quick yeah
real quick 30 more minutes real quick 17
well I like it down that's a guy with
passion that's a mean you know cuz a lot
of times we'll get a guy calling hey you
got any questioning and i just wanna say
hey yeah that's a good that's a good
[ __ ] a good call anyway we were in
the car covered a lot of [ __ ] we were
talking about rinse and I'm a trained TV
I'm paying 1534 but it's gone up every
year since I've been living there yeah
I'm rent control right kind of kind of
what do you mean it keeps going up yeah
but three percent only right yeah yeah
that's legal a lot of people don't know
their rights and and I don't know my
rights yeah they told me hey it's 1800
next year I'd be like okay no no that's
wrong email i said i never go for that
always got to be three what years your
building built you know no idea well
it's got to be like sixties at we you
know does anyone know if it has that
thing on the front door that to say
there's chemicals in here that'll kill
you yeah yeah yeahs up man hey that's a
good man [ __ ] in here yet so yeah it's
eating from 84 on no rent control so
you're under rent control and legally
you cannot charge somebody more than
three percent a year so that's why it's
only increments and if you get in a
rent-controlled building in this town
it's almost like you got to stay in it
yeah you know because as soon as you
move out your apartment it's going to be
two grand yeah you know time in
everything around me is two grand yeah
and I and I got the serious wake-up call
even my new place now which is 1550 I
was really fired up when I found it and
then I went from months of like oh I
hate it here i made the wrong move to
now loving it again because i realized
as i'm on the road i come home i got is
it create a part
man you know it really is a great
apartment I don't care much for the
people around the place you know like
like I said I don't really relate to any
of the people in the stuff but I don't
go to those those shops anymore at first
I was like this is my new hood I'm
hitting this place and this is going to
be where I'm eating bread with I just go
to the one on one now yeah I get on the
bike and and it gets me out of the house
yep the quality of the apartment is so
[ __ ] good that I don't even care
about what's going on around because the
quiet the neighborhood is quiet that
partments quiet and its bits good size
and I got the grant of this place I got
a big [ __ ] place for what I'm paying
man at any time if I'd [ __ ] start
starving out I can get a roommate in
that second room there cuz at first I
was like this is gonna be the podcast
studio and there's like oh god the
upstairs is 9,000 degrees in the summer
that was a hot summer that cooked my
brain of you got to get out of here yeah
and then now it's cooling off and a my
kids cool here you know to him like it's
you know it's [ __ ] rough out there
what up so anyway back to the final
amoeba thing it's not going anywhere for
years but it will eventually and they
were from what I hear we're secretly
planning on move in any way downtown
well I'm fine if they open up a new
place i'm not i don't care about that as
long as you have the stuff yeah the same
oh yeah they're not going anywhere yeah
yeah if they reopen a new one I'm cool
with that I don't care where it is and
it might be interesting I talked about
this yesterday with somebody records are
red hot right now but he could fade off
and it'll just be back to the people
like you or I and friends that love
vinyl yeah and turntables and vintage
gear and all that stuff when it gets
back down to that and the because you
know it's the record companies are
greedy and they're charging thirty
dollars for a new [ __ ] piece of vinyl
which is just [ __ ] [ __ ] cuz they
know they can get away with it right now
it's hot but when neg cooks back down
which it will I think it'll fade off you
know what I mean because streaming is
just getting bigger and bigger and
bigger like iTunes you know everything
he knew you by now you get the download
you they get right there trying to throw
in all these extra things to make it
seem like you get more yeah painting all
the code it's like an eighth edition
blue vinyl yeah it's like I don't even
see the color of I know when it's on the
table i'm back on the couch actly i
don't give a [ __ ] what color it is at
first I did I was like God like I got a
black chrism orica and white vinyl it's
[ __ ] cool but it's like original when
it came out you know I don't go down now
like okay I need the blue vinyl one you
know that being said that hologram vinyl
I'm so lievable the star wars were you
got oh so good I can love that one man
but um so amoeba could potentially and I
[ __ ] on downtown on stage as a joke but
I absolutely am starting to love
downtown more and more and more over the
last year I'm down there a lot doing
comedy mm-hmm I really [ __ ] like it
and I think I figured out the layout now
before I'd always be like I ate it down
here one way street where the [ __ ] is
everything but now I've learned it and
if I could find a [ __ ] small loft
down there and wasn't a million dollars
I would be down there in a minute look I
know yeah right exactly exactly but I
really like they got all they got all
kinds of restaurants down there and if
amoeba moves down and some crew [ __ ]
kind of a lofty warehouse that'll be hip
and they can do like late-night they
could do concerts in there with the in
stores and [ __ ] you know and and and cut
some of the fat in that store some of
the store you know like like eventually
no one's going to buy DVDs we don't need
the second floor who's buying dvds so
that second floor could be gone and
really concentrate on vinyl and just
have all vinyl and you know what I mean
because people sure CDs are still going
but how much longer mm-hmm who even has
a CD player some people have them in a
car you got one in your car now yeah and
I got a 13 yeah right
internet doesn't have one yeah so anyway
no worries there my I guess the moral of
the story is here it I can see Hollywood
turnin into turning into san fran you
know it's gonna get higher and higher
here I don't understand how more stuff
goes away and and people still the town
gets hotter like people still move in
here like yeah i heard they got nothing
let me move there you know the young
businessman i know everyone wants to be
famous cuz everything that we we love
about this city is slowly going away so
once it's all gone away you know and
show business is just gonna turn into
[ __ ] garbage just people doing home
videos on the phone to youtube yeah so
you can just do show business in
oklahoma yeah you know honey boo boo
that could be any [ __ ] where mm-hmm
anyway let's get out of here thanks for
tuning everybody I'll see you this week
in North Carolina with bill burr I'm at
the carolina theatre three nights
thursday friday saturday and in edmonton
i'm coming to see your headline in the
comic strip into September through
October second then New York City
October a sorry 12th through the 18th at
the stand and one night at Gotham thank
you guys all for tuning in leave those
reviews and subscribe keep the candles
lit thanks Biddle's for stopping by yeah
man hell yeah man and tell him where you
at on Instagram and young shows at BB
combs this week i'm in hollywood him at
the improv tonight i'm at the store and
i'll be down this weekend steve simmons
recording his album so i'm gonna be
opening for him where la jolla Comedy
Store always recording his record is
done a second one yeah oh wow a second
new stuff mhm hilaire says it gym today
and say one thing about it anyway yeah
great episode thanks for the great calls
you guys all rock keep the candles let's
see you later